hello there you're watching the press
preview our first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive and it's time
to see what's making the headlines with
the daily mails consultant editor andrew
pearce and the daily mirrors associate
editor kevin mcguire so very good
evening to both of you really lovely to
see you both
and they will be with us from now until
just before midnight so lots to talk
about let's take a look first of all at
the front pages of tomorrow's papers and
the guardian leads on the news that all
children aged 5 to 11 will be offered a
covert jab
in the wake of prince andrew's
settlement with virginia giffrey and the
opening of a police investigation into
allegations of cash for honours at one
of prince charles's charities the metro
has the headline plutonium jubilee
but the sun is in an upbeat mood
declaring thank god for the queen
the daily mail however reports that
prince charles could be interviewed by
the police as they investigate claims
that is ch over his charity uh over
allegations of cash for honours
which is also the lead for the times
the foreign secretary liz truss writes
for the telegraph insisting the russian
president vladimir putin will
deliberately prolong the crisis in
ukraine in an attempt to test the mettle
of the west
the financial times hears that the
french government is calling for an
overhaul of eu security protocols in an
attempt to better tackle the ukrainian
situation
and a reminder that by scanning the qr
code that you can see on screen during
the program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's papers while you
watch us
so andrew pearce and kevin mcguire are
here with me to go through some of those
papers and a lot of front pages go
andrew with uh
the royal family with prince charles
being the latest to hit the headlines
you've picked up the daily mail's take
on it first of all
charles facing police quiz over cash for
honours coming hard on the heels of
prince andrews settlement with virginia
giffrey in the civil case yesterday
yeah so this is you could hardly make it
up it couldn't have been a worse 24
hours for the royal family you think
back to the queen's anna cerublus in
1992 when everything seemed to go wrong
divorces and fires at windsor castle but
now the future king the heir to the
throne may be questioned by the police
over uh allegations that someone within
his or his prince's foundation
was offering in return for donations uh
to uh bump up uh honours for
for at least one saudi businessman uh uh
this was widely reported in the mail on
sunday and the the the sunday times last
autumn
and now the police have decided there's
enough there to warrant a full
investigation why they announced it uh
today i have no idea um but it's
extraordinary timing we bet we barely
caught our breath from the shock waves
of prince andrew falling on his sword
com uh making a settlement with virginia
dufrese when we were told only a week
ago he was going to fight it in court
then to hear that the prince of wales
may be questioned himself is astonishing
absolutely astonishing obviously it's an
investigation there's lots of a lot a
lot of ground can be covered before it
gets very serious but the mere idea of
prince charles facing potentially being
questioned by the police when we might
have our own prime minister being
questioned by the police too probably a
similar unit of police officers you
could it it is we're in uncharted waters
here well yes and clarence house have
reiterated its previous insistence
haven't they that prince charles had no
knowledge of the alleged offer of
honours or british citizenship on the
basis of a donation to his charities and
they point out that he's president of
the foundation but isn't involved with
its governance um with the charities
trustees overseeing day-to-day
activities but kevin what do you make of
this um
the met police announcing that they are
going to be investigating this the fact
that they're putting it into the public
domain does that is that a measure of
the seriousness with which they're
taking this yeah prince charles was
quite happy when the uh foundation
bought don frieser house in scotland
which he rather likes
anyway um i was surprised at the timing
presumably it was pre-planned um
prince andrew may be breathing a slight
uh sigh of relief that the focus has
gone from him uh to some extent to his
uh elder brother er the throne who may
have got tough with him down the line
when
their mother uh leaves this mortal coil
at uh at some time but what a mess for
the royals this is a family that's
supposed to be above all others uh
superior it's a hierarchy family always
had a state they
have a very privileged entitled
positions and this is an incredible mess
and i i hear prince charles and we we
hear his uh denials but the
the sale of honors is uh is illegal uh
it has been since 1925 after lloyd
jordan a a liberal and a national
liberal uh prime minister was found to
have been selling knighthoods for ten
thousand i think it was baronet seas for
thirty thousand appearances for fifty
thousand plus uh there was a an
investigation by the police into
allegations uh during tony blair's reign
and no charges were brought um the
police aren't investigating allegations
that uh
conservative party treasurers seem to
get uh peerages uh after they've given
three million plus and uh spent their
time here but this is incredibly serious
for somebody like the uh from prince
charles um
given that he's one of those who gets
his sword out and puts it on the
shoulders and and hands out the medals
and pins them on people's uh chest so he
has nothing to do about it but you can't
imagine a worse time for the royals on
the back of andrew's settlement 10 12
million
giving money to a woman he claimed he'd
never met uh
and and didn't know
uh ahead of the queen's uh jubilee a
platinum jubilee in in the summer it's
uh it all feels to be uh falling apart
well yes you say platinum jubilee the
metro calls it plutonium jubilee don't
they um andrew uh
an explosive headline there they talk
about it being another royal scandal and
there are photographs of the queen
seen in in public we've seen her doing
zoom calls but this was a meeting i
think she had in person um today
and obviously everyone pleased to see
her up on her feet um but uh
this this does to a certain extent take
the shine off a year that's supposed to
be all about celebration for her
yeah look this is probably this is one
of the most important years of her reign
if not the most important no other
monarch
in our history has got to 70 years she
got to that point on february the 6th
which is when she acceded to the throne
on the death of her father george vi
june is pencilled in it's not pencilling
he's inked him for a series of
celebrations two bank holidays the whole
country even kevin mcguire might be
cheering and giving thanks for the
fantastic 70 years of service she's
given and yet the year is being
dominated of course he won't because
he's republican kev but of course the
year is being overshadowed by two great
scandals it's a great scandal involving
prince andrew the queen is almost
certainly going to have to contribute to
the cost of the legal settlement that
money cannot come from public funds
because there would rightly be an outcry
over that so i think there's going to
have to be some transparency over that
and then of course
charles is in trouble and it's all
linked to the man who's been with him
for 25 30 years michael fawcett who ran
the prince's foundation the man who
wrote the letter to this saudi
businessman a billionaire a man who gave
a lot of money done for his house up in
scotland which is one of prince
charles's pets projects uh he was first
of all suspended and then he resigned
from working for the prince and that was
a big blow for prince charles because
fawcett and prince charles were almost
inseparable he is the official i can
tell you it's not an urban myth he is
the official who once put toothpaste on
prince charles toothbrush because prince
charles had knackered one of his arms
and couldn't do it himself that shows
how close they have been and he will no
doubt be denying these allegations and
looking at the metro here with this
plutonium jubilee headline kevin you
were saying that in some ways prince
andrew will be breathing a sigh of
relief because it's not him on the front
pages for a second day in a row and yet
there's been a lot of discussion through
the day today haven't there
about um the case that that he has
settled and andrew mentioned the money
there um do you think we will find out
how much money has been paid and where
it's come from
um i don't know i think we deserve to
know because these aren't private
matters this this is somebody who's in
line to the throne part of a a ruling
hereditary monarchy that is there uh
through public acceptance really look uh
they're descended from warlords but uh
that they're tolerated or supported
because they're seen to be better and
good for the country now if one of them
is settling a
sex abuse case with a woman he claimed
he didn't know and then his team was
smearing then all of a sudden she's
getting 10 to 12 million pounds money
going to her charity apologies are
issued in a groveling statement
uh all of a sudden he's prints out who's
going to campaign against sex
trafficking which
given the allegations i find a bit
stomach uh
churning we should we deserve to know we
also deserve to know what his mother as
the monarch has paid both from the
sovereign grant and the inherited uh
wealth that she she has they can't just
claim their ordinary citizens because
they're not it just isn't the case but
we see what links the two uh scandals
and they are scandals one involving
prince charles and i know he is denying
any knowledge and prince andu who is
denying any
guilt or wrongdoing what links them is
they're giving elevated positions and
they have huge entitlement uh they have
considerable patronage and incredible
privilege and it is how is that
exercised and is it good in a modern
democracy
that you have these people who are there
just by a throw with the dna dice and
accent of birth being elevated against
all of us and i would suggest that i'm
sorry i'm sorry for the queen on a human
level she's 95. uh she lost her husband
you've got to feel sorry for her but the
whole ruritanian
nonsense is just falling apart okay and
and that brings us to andre i know
you're shaking your head i just want to
show everyone that the sun here thank
god for the queen i mean do you think as
as kevin is hinting there that this
might put people off the whole idea of
the monarchy or do you think the queen's
popularity means that that people are
all for the royal family do you think
this changes anything
i think it's not good it's a it's a very
bad couple of days for the royal family
and if this police investigation into
charles goes much further that would be
bad too but look the queen is hugely
popular in incredibly popular she won't
use any of the sovereign grant to settle
andrew's bills it'll come from her own
private income which we don't know how
large it is but she has we know she's
got a private income she will be
fastidious and and and make sure
everything is done properly and i tell
you people will there will be street
parties there will be buntings there
will be great happiness when it's the
queen's jubilee celebrations in june old
commercially mcguire might not be he'll
probably clear off out of the country
with all his republican mates well good
riddance we don't need him here we'll
all have a very good time and let me
tell you when the queen departs and we
don't want to lose her charles will be a
very popular king and in the years after
that william and kate will be even more
popular they're they're the great stars
in the making
kevin we haven't already got time two
seconds much better
yes andrew bender and me cannot
guarantee that charles will be popular i
don't doubt
the queen's popularity but the problem
for the monarchy who read every monarchy
is she that's popular but what comes
next is not guaranteed to be popular
okay and just as i as i end this
particular section i do want to show
everyone the mac cartoon um it's uh
someone with a it's a fire man fire
person what do you say these days i
can't remember go and check that windsor
castle hasn't caught fire they say the
queen is having one of those years so a
great cartoon from matt as ever we're
going to take a pause right there don't
go anywhere uh let's uh tell you what's
coming up after the break is vladimir
putin trying to deliberately prolong the
crisis in ukraine we'll discuss that
next
welcome back you're watching the press
preview with me tonight andrew pierce
and kevin mcguire and we've got the the
chunky subjects of ukraine and covert to
grapple with in this short section um
but let's take a look at the daily
telegraph andrew shall we and they've
got an interview with the foreign
secretary
yeah liz trust
it's an article she's written actually
anna and she's saying that she thinks
this this sprinkmanship could go on for
months and i think she's absolutely
right i thought for quite a while now
that putin is not going to go piling in
the ukraine uh it would be a long and
bloody conflict uh it could be dragged
on for months and months he's
only painfully aware of how winter wars
could go horribly wrong uh he's built up
the biggest uh troops mass it's we've
seen in europe since the second world
war and i think this is his policy he's
mobilizing uh and he's galvanizing
public opinion
and i think that's what it's all about
it's it's showmanship from the great
showman and the great pr operator that's
vladimir putin he's a terrible loyal
gangster
and he's got ukraine completely under
his thumb uh and he's got all these
world leaders rushing to moscow to to a
jaw jaw with him and i think he's just
reveling in all and reveling in all of
it and kevin it's interesting that
andrew there talks about putin being a
pr man but it's interesting the pr that
the western allies have put forward as
well we heard from the u.s president
that they thought a particular time was
the timing of the invasion we've got liz
trust now writing articles about it is
this quite unusual this kind of very
open discussion of the tactics
yeah well this is liz trots who
yesterday was saying the invasion was
imminent now uh she's she's saying he
could drag up this crisis on for months
and of course it could because putin is
a very dangerous nationalist or
authoritarian
but he will he will play games and and i
think western countries have to be a bit
more careful uh how our politicians
respond because at one point
you had voices in london and washington
being far more hysterical about it than
in kiev in ukraine itself and he he will
play games now the ukrainians have been
used to this for uh for eight years
since
the annexation of uh the crimea um we'll
be able to discuss this
in more detail a bit later but a quick
look at the front page of the guardian
kevin i know you wanted to comment on
this the fact that the covert jab
program is now being extended to primary
school children
yeah announced in england uh 5 to 11
after scotland and wales got a got a bit
of a lead on it but it's it's voluntary
and it's going to be fascinating to see
how many parents now get their children
uh jabbed in that age group because it's
not it's not becoming compulsory you're
not being told you should or must do it
it is far more voluntary
and very quickly andrew so this country
rolling out the jabs to more age groups
some of us have had three jabs maybe
even more and yet there are some
countries in the world who are barely
managing to to vaccinate their people
once
i know it's this terrible dilemma should
we be giving more vaccines to the third
world we are we have given a lot but
actually the first duty of the
government is to protect its citizens
and a lot of primary school aged
children have been struck down by covid
so i think it's fantastic this is being
made available but it is up to parents
and they'll make the decision and good
and good luck tonight we must leave it
together i hope they do get them jabbed
we must leave it there more from you at
11. thank you
you